okay so um displacement and velocity
right velocity is a function of time
so a more sort of abbreviated way of
saying that
is just to name a function call it you
know
v right and to indicate that its
variable is time
you slap a um a t there okay v
velocity of time okay but obviously
because velocity is always a function of
time
we generally sort of abbreviate it to
that in much the same way
that when you're doing you know um
coordinate geometry
you don't say y of x all the time
because y is always of x
x is always the input so you just say y
and the same way you just say v
okay now since velocity is about how the
displacement's changing
okay and we said you differentiate the
displacement function and that gives you
velocity
okay that means that drawing back on all
of your
rates of change understanding okay
velocity is dx on your t
okay you differentiate once with respect
to t
okay now in all the textbooks what
you'll find in exams as well
instead of calling this x dash because
dash is usually what we use to indicate
differentiation right to indicate that
it's slightly different
that it's with respect to time not
x whatever that is we write x dot
instead of
x dash okay i used to get really
irritated but it's like why
why another thing it's so confusing um
but i've come to actually appreciate
because it sort of
signals to you okay this is a motion
question and you're also
you're differentiating with respect to
time and that's important
okay so there's the notation
okay just to extend this idea right i'm
not going to deal with it fully because
i'm going to leave it till tomorrow
velocity is how displacement is changing
right
well we also have an understanding of
how velocity is changing when we give it
a name we call it
acceleration right so acceleration
i'm just going to give you the notation
for it and then we'll discuss it
tomorrow because acceleration
in a mathematical sense is actually
there's some
counter-intuitive things to it which i
want to give some more time to explain
it
okay i'll just show you how to write it
acceleration's
also a function of time
so i'm going to write it as a of t
okay which we just shortened to a right
now i said acceleration is how
velocity is changing okay so therefore
you have to take velocity right and
differentiate it with respect to time
but since v itself is a derivative
right to differentiate again it's just
like saying well
just don't worry about velocity in
between
just get it straight from displacement
and differentiate twice
right so the second derivative of
displacement
brings us down to acceleration okay you
can probably guess instead of x dot it's
going to be
x double dot
it looks like a yeah it looks like a
it's miffy okay great uh anyway so there
you go
um that's how you write acceleration and
you will see it start to appear
in the exercises that i'm gonna give you
okay now like i said
particularly when it comes to like
positive and negative
and acceleration and deceleration and
what do those even mean
they'll take some time so i'm going to
deal with them tomorrow okay but i just
wanted to introduce that i'm not going
to